hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the three different states of
matter
remember that matter is what makes up
everything around you matter is anything
that occupies space and has the mass and
all different kinds of matter can exist
in three possible States depending on
the temperature and pressure that the
matter is at those states are solid
liquid and gas now if you're interested
in learning more about the different
types of matter please see my video on
classification of matter but now let's
talk about these three different states
I have drawn here images of what water
molecules look like in their solid
configuration what we know of as ice in
their liquid configuration so liquid
water and in their gaseous configuration
water vapour now we can see that they
certainly have some differences let's
start by talking about shape and volume
in solid water like an ice cube both the
shape of the ice cube and the volume of
the ice cube are fixed liquid water
however still has a fixed volume meaning
it takes up the same amount of space but
its shape is not fixed this is because
liquid water takes on the shape of its
container so let's say that you have a
glass of water the water takes the shape
of that glass if you then pour the water
on the floor or pour the water into a
vase or pour the water into a shallow
bowl in all of these instances the water
will take
on a different shape with gases like
water vapor both the shape and the
volume are unfixed think about water
that is coming from a boil so you've got
boiling water and water vapor is
evaporating off the top of the boiling
water that water vapor will move outward
expanding until it fills the entire room
so water vapor like all gases it has a
shape and volume that is not fixed
meaning it takes on both the shape and
the volume of its container another good
example of this is a balloon if you
think about blowing up a balloon the gas
that you put inside the balloon will
take on the shape and the volume of the
balloon now let's talk about two other
kinds of characteristics that is the
speed of particles how quickly they're
moving and the proximity of particles
how close or far apart they are from
each other we'll talk about speed of
particles first and gasses particles are
moving very rapidly on the other end of
the spectrum the speed of particles in a
solid is quite slow and liquids the
speed of their particles are at more of
an intermediate range belongs this
continuum now let's take a second to
talk about whether or not it's possible
for particles to completely stop when we
think about the particles of a solid
like an ice cube
or a chair or a mark
it seems like if you just put those
things down on a table they don't move
you see zero movement however the
individual particles in the solid are
moving they're moving very slowly but
they are moving most of the movement is
more of a vibrational movement and this
is simply because the atoms and the
bonds and the atoms they do have energy
with their vibrational energy in order
for the particles to have zero movements
to be completely still they have to
reach something called absolute zero
which is zero Kelvin on the Kelvin
temperature scale this is when movement
completely stops because there's no
energy left if you're interested in
learning more about the Kelvin
temperature scale please see my video on
converting between different temperature
scales however in most cases solids
still have some degree of movement even
though it's very very slow in fact
there's no place on earth that is as
cold as absolute zero so all solids on
earth are still going to be moving
somewhat even if it's just very slowly
now let's talk about proximity of
particles this means how near or far the
particles are kamichan in solids you can
see they're very very close together
so the various particles that are making
up solids are very close together they
often have a crystalline type of lattice
work that keeps them all very close
together gases on the other hand tends
to be very far apart so far apart that
they're only bouncing off of each other
occasionally and again liquid particles
tend to be in the middle of this range
where they are closer together than
solid particles excuse me they are
farther apart than solid particles but
closer together than gaseous particles
so that is it for these three states of
matter I hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching biology put out
there